backstage you said something you said
that short form is a gateway to long
form so what would your strategy be for
that it means that a lot of long-form
creators don't focus on short form and
vice versa there's a reason I have one
hour keynote videos and one hour podcast
but also pound unlimited micro content
that's 10 seconds long you can go very
tactical and you know a lot of people
want to hear that they're like should I
make a tick tock that says watch the
rest on YouTube it's less about that
people will find you they become
intrigued your url strategy on all your
social networks should be very
thoughtful I'm constantly changing them
based on whatever my objectives are but
just means that the world of content
creating should be always thought about
as and and I noticed that everybody's
into ore right people are insecure most
of you did not start on Tick Tock fast
enough because you didn't have followers
on it you didn't start on Tick Tock fast
enough because you had 80 000 followers
on Instagram and you had zero and Tick
Tock and you didn't like that feeling
that's why celebrities lost the first
time around so like the things that you
made fun of people for on Instagram you
became on tick